i
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el estado de
florida ha captado la atención no sólo
de eeuu sino también del mundo entero al
ser aprobada la ley de derechos de los
padres en la educación llamada
popularmente como ley donde gay o no
digas' gay la propuesta de ley contó con
un fuerte patrocinio de los republicanos
e indica que los temas relacionados con
orientación sexual e identidad de género
desde el jardín de infantes hasta tercer
grado de primaria debe ser abordado por
los padres y no por los maestros veamos
un extracto de esta ley dice claramente
la instrucción en el aula por parte de
las personas de la escuela o de terceros
sobre orientación sexual o identidad de
género no puede ocurrir desde el jardín
de infantes hasta el tercer grado o de
una manera que no sea apropiada para la
edad o el desarrollo de los estudiantes
de acuerdo con los estándares estatales
estándar es precisamente entonces que
hay de las leyes o estándares federales
a la hora de decidir este tipo de
situaciones la medida ha sido defendida
a capa y espada por el gobernador del
estado de florida el republicano ron de
santis el gobernador en varias de sus
declaraciones ha indicado que de esta
manera nos aseguramos de que los padres
puedan enviar a sus hijos a la escuela
para recibir una educación no
adoctrinamiento
educación sexual y explicación sobre
identidad de género de manera temprana
es adoctrinamiento pues esa es una de
las preguntas que le vamos a hacer a uno
de nuestros invitados es una de las
preguntas que ha llegado a través de las
redes sociales a france24 la ley ha
causado todo tipo de debates protestas
también discrepancias y opiniones los
demócratas han afirmado que esta ley
demoniza a la comunidad lgbt
plus al excluirla de las conversaciones
en los salones de clase a temprana edad
incluso desde la casa blanca el
presidente joe biden calificó esta
medida como odiosa se están violando los
derechos de esta comunidad que tanto es
esto una estrategia del gobernador de
santis que es un político que está en
ascenso y que buscará ser candidato a la
presidencia en el año 2024 que tanto
beneficio tendrá para los menores y que
tanta responsabilidad deberán asumir
entonces los padres para poder hablar
sobre estos temas que hay con los
menores de edad que desde muy temprana
edad tienen confusión sobre su identidad
sexual y deben hablar sobre este tema
la polémica ley donde entonces que yo no
digas gay
nuestro tema de debate en france 24 y
para analizarlo hemos invitado a víctor
de la flor él es abogado y también
vicepresidente de la república national
hispanic asamblea del condado de
miami-dade él se encuentra pues como el
nombre de la institución lo dice en la
ciudad de miami también allí en el sur
de la florida se conecta a esta
conversación alejandro acosta él es
activista lgtb es director de política
pública y también abogacía de arianna
center ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en este debate
con todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas por supuesto las pueden hacer
a través de nuestras redes sociales no
se encuentran en facebook en instagram y
en twitter estamos como france24 guión
bajo s arroba sant y luego que esté en
cuenta personal y nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas comienzo
entonces con el víctor de la flor allí
en la ciudad de miami preguntándole por
su opinión como punto de partida
pregunta básica para el inicio del
debate su opinión sobre esta ley
aprobada en el estado de florida
ahora entiendo buenas tardes muchas
gracias por tu invitación yo creo que
esta ley es una ley innecesaria pero el
estado de florida y bueno yo no le diría
que es una ley de no digas gay dado que
si es un apodo impuesto por los
demócratas para generar una imagen
negativa de módica de esta legislación
yo creo que efectivamente la ley
denominada de los derechos de los padres
en la educación es una ley importante
porque básicamente son los padres los
encargados de educar a los hijos y no
los maestros y menos adoctrinar los de
alejandro para el punto de partida su
opinión sobre esta ley y lo que ha
repercutido en la sociedad desde el
estado de florida y también en los eeuu
y ya vemos que tiene eco internacional
por eso estamos analizando este tema
fuera de las fronteras de eeuu
como bien mencionaste la ley aparenta
hacer un movimiento político del
gobernador de santes quien tiene
aspiraciones a ser presidente en el 2000
acá en el 2024 estar en lo que hace
efectivamente es invisibilizar la
comunidad lgtb y promover el odio y las
herramientas necesarias para enseñar
educación sexual muchas veces los padres
no las tienen porque tampoco se les
enseñó desde pequeños eso en su casa
cuando usted enseña a los estudiantes
sobre su propia sexualidad sobre sus
partes privadas también se está
previniendo el abuso sexual se está
dando el poder a esa es a esas personas
pequeñas no a tener autoridad sobre su
cuerpo nos está adoctrinando a nada yo
fui maestro por 17 años abiertamente gay
en escuelas públicas en puerto rico en
chicago y en florida también entré a
maestros en educación sexual y la
cantidad de mitos y de mala información
que tienen los maestros sus
administradores y los padres es
increíble promueve
enfermedades la misión sexual al igual
que el vih
alejandro continuo con usted para hacer
la ronda a la inversa preguntándole si
se están violando derechos de esta
comunidad de la comunidad lgtb
y si se está violando de manera temprana
derechos de estos menores de edad que
posiblemente muchos de ellos van a ser
parte de esta comunidad de una vez
tengan clara cuál es su identidad sexual
probablemente los estudiantes que son el
gt que tiene de 40% más probabilidad de
cometer suicidio y cerca y auto a auto a
hacerse daño no los estudiantes entran a
jardín a veces ya con una identidad
diferente a la que nacieron por cierto
para determinar un sexo puede ser que
una estudiante nazca intersex o 1.4 por
ciento de la población de los estados
unidos es intersex o que no tienen una
tiene a veces ambos ambos órganos padre
internos y externos quien determina lo
que es un varón que el término que es
una niña
actualmente en eeuu todo hay muchos
estados que están promoviendo la
educación desde jardín hasta que se
salga en escuadra superior porque evita
embarazos abortos no no hay manera de
justificar lo que están haciendo los
republicanos simplemente esto es una
estrategia para eliminar e invisibilizar
la comunidad
víctor en la ciudad de miami le pregunto
entonces cuál es el motivo el fin de
haber promovido esta ley de llevarla a
cabo y de imponer la ya de forma de
acuerdo como lo estipula la ley en el
estado de florida para ponerla en marcha
con es el fin
el fin es que los padres tomen la
tomen la obligación de educar a sus
hijos correctamente una vez más quienes
deben educar a los hijos son los padres
no los maestros en ese aspecto de temas
de identidad sexual lo que estaba
hablando digamos en el otro compañero es
acerca del vih de violaciones etcétera
de abortos
no creo que esos sean temas interesantes
para un niño del jardín no un niño de
primero segundo incluso tercer grado de
primaria entonces la idea aquí es
empoderar a los padres en cuanto al
derecho que ellos deben ejercer en la
educación de sus hijos y para contestar
el tema en cuanto a la violación de
derechos civiles no hay ninguna
violación de derechos civiles porque la
ley no indica que y no
digamos no indica que se restrinja de
cierta manera ciertas discusiones
espontáneas acerca de la orientación
sexual o de la identidad de género en
que es completamente razonable si es que
algún niño pudiera tener ese tipo de
duda lo que está diciendo la ley
incluir esa temática dentro de un plan
de estudios oficial
ese es el punto de la ley es tener un
plan de estudio correcto para que el
niño que estamos hablando niños de
menores de 8 años puedan tener
simplemente una un inicio en la
educación totalmente libre de estos
temas que muy probablemente no ni
siquiera van a entender
si alejandro continuó con usted para
preguntarle si son los padres de familia
las personas perfectamente capacitadas
para asumir este tipo de conversaciones
vemos que incluso todavía muchos adultos
en la actualidad tienen confusión en
cuanto a la definición de algunas
identidades de género son los padres las
personas adecuadas para hablar este tipo
de
temas con sus hijos es normal hablar con
los padres cualquier tipo de tema pero
está en puntualidad
para ser puntuales y requiere cierto
conocimiento o capacitación para
entender muchos aspectos que tal vez los
padres no tienen o que piensa usted al
respecto
el caso es que muchos padres si podrán
tener las herramientas para educar a sus
hijos pero muchos otros no especialmente
en estas comunidades latinas tenemos la
religión el machismo y hay muchas muchas
específica individualidades sociales que
a lo mejor
prohíben a los padres a tener una buena
educación sexual de sus hijos inclusive
aún cuando están preparados la educación
sexual cambia constantemente es dinámica
y es difícil en general hablar con
nosotros no conserva niños con adultos
punto mismos muy bien dice sobre
sexualidad es por eso que es importante
que sea de una manera que vaya de
acuerdo a su edad es esta esta ley no
simplemente prohíbe las discusiones
entre primero desde jardín hasta tercer
grado también le da las herramientas a
los padres para demandar a los maestros
a los administradores y a cualquier
persona que ellos consideren que hayan
violado la ley de cualquier manera para
parecida de iu de texas con relación a
los abortos un dato interesante es que
en misisipí por ejemplo no se puede dar
educación sexual a los dictadores que
actualmente tienen las leyes de don
siegel y en el estado misisipí hasta el
1020 eran el estado con mayor embarazo
en
[Música]
en adolescentes entonces es muy muy
irónico que el estado con mayor
embarazos de adolescentes es uno de los
estados que no permite que se hable de
sexualidad ni tampoco se hable de
educación sexual en la escuela solo de
abstinencia eso no actualmente con el
peso que tienen los niños en internet y
había pornografía que le llega
literalmente a su casa es
importante que reciban una manera
educada de una manera 6ta y por una
persona educada como un maestro
víctor usted lo mencionaba la ley no
prohíbe conversaciones espontáneas
acerca de la orientación sexual o de la
identidad de género en las escuelas
pero en qué momento se empieza a cruzar
la línea si surge una conversación entre
un maestro y un grupo de alumnos sobre
este tema y se empieza a dar allí un
debate y una explicación sobre este tema
en qué momento deja de ser una
conversación espontánea y en qué momento
deja de ser un adoctrinamiento que es
como el gobernador lo ha llamado
a este tipo de diálogos y conversaciones
o temáticas en las clases de educación
sexual
yo creo que el adoctrinamiento va a
venir siempre que esté este plan se
encuentre dentro de la temática oficial
de estudios sea si es que este debate se
impone dentro de la currícula
básicamente desde
desde estudios no o sea haber para esto
hay que ver por qué nace esta norma en
principio hubo denuncias de padres por
adoctrinamiento de género en el jardín
de infantes habían profesores que
obligan a niños a participar en marcha
de uruguay en la escuela o maestras de
vistiendo la busca vistiendo de niños de
mujeres entonces los padres no quieren
eso y es y está bien porque una vez más
los padres son los que tienen toda la
responsabilidad de educar a sus hijos y
el derecho y la obligación de educar a
sus hijos entonces
si si bien pueden haber este tipo de
discusiones espontáneas en la idea es
evitar que desde la currícula estatal se
imponga este estos temas que los niños
una vez más no lo van a entender en ese
momento
víctor los demócratas y algunos sectores
de la sociedad allí en florida y también
en otros estados de eeuu han dicho que
el lenguaje de esta ley es ambiguo que
se presta para que cualquier
conversación sobre estos temas pueda dar
pie a que demanden los padres y creando
tal vez una atmósfera complicada entre
las instituciones educativas los padres
de familia y los estudiantes dicen que
hay palabras que no son precisas y que
se prestan como ya lo decía yo para la
ambigüedad para usted la ley es clara es
correcta tal cual como está redactada o
tiene que ser un poco más precisa da
bueno en eeuu ninguna ley es totalmente
clara todas las leyes son dispuestas a
ser para poder ser interpretadas y para
eso también tenemos una corte digamos
una una un poder judicial que puede
interpretar la ley en el caso concreto
pero la ley es digamos suficientemente
clara en el sentido de que no se debe
imponer esta está este tipo de ideología
o este tipo de adoctrinamiento a los
niños una vez más las discusiones
espontáneas ahora lo que está diciendo
es cuál es la línea de división al punto
gris ok habrá un punto gris pero también
hay que recordar que en los profesores
siempre van a estar
circunscritos a la currícula
entonces ellos tienen que tener la
capacidad de discernir cuándo se puede
tocar ciertos temas o cuándo no
si víctor su opinión perdón a alejandro
su opinión al respecto sobre esta
mención a los demócratas hay en florida
sobre esta posible ambigüedad de la ley
es muy ambigua en ejemplo de dije no no
es simplemente del jardín a tercer grado
también la ley dice que cualquier
cualquier forma que la persona se sienta
incómoda y que piense que el maestro el
profesor rompió con la ley ellos pueden
demandar entonces en el por ejemplo la
asociación de pediatras
recomienda que la educación sexual esté
comience en el jardín la organización
por ejemplo a toques orius tiene un
currículo que comienza en que inter card
en terminar en el grado 12 estos son
llevados por los estándares federales de
educación sexual en el estado de florida
tiene 67 distritos escolares y al mismo
tiempo tiene 67 maneras de enseñar
educación sexual y no tiene que haber
una manera de una informar izar la
educación sexual al igual que cualquier
otra materia no hay por qué tenerle
miedo a la sexualidad hay niños que
llegan al jardín ya con pregunto y
materialmente con preguntas sobre su
identidad sexual y su identidad de
género entonces hay niños que tienen
papás y mamás que son del mismo sexo
toda esa conversación están prohibidas
desde desde el jardín hasta el grado
tercer yo cuando desde el principio de
la década del 2000
estaba incluyendo a familias que son
diferentes no todo el mundo tiene papá y
mamá hay niños que viven con sus tíos
con sus abuelos con amigos no podemos
excluir a las personas que no caen en un
molde en un molde de papá mamá es por
eso que la inclusión es importante
víctor le transfiero ese es el
comentario que hace alejandro que hay de
los niños que hacen parte de familias
que han sido adoptadas o que ya han
nacido en el seno de una familia donde
los padres son del mismo sexo no podrán
hablar sobre este tema en su escuela
abiertamente con sus profesores y sus
compañeros y hablar de este tipo de
temas que hay de ese tipo de personas
entre los compañeros no hay ningún
límite la ley no impone ningún límite
para las discusiones entre los entre los
niños y la parte importante una vez más
que se tiene que
tomar en cuenta y resaltar aquí es que
no debe haber un tipo de temática o plan
de estudios oficial en ese sentido pero
los niños pueden discutir eso y si
tienen alguna otra duda tendrían que
discutirlo con los padres y los padres
eventualmente quizás discutirlo con los
profesionales que puedan ayudarlo pero
esa es la idea de la ley no se empodera
a los padres en cuanto a la educación y
en ningún momento se está indicando que
los niños no pueden hablar
espontáneamente de lo que ellos
esto también entonces víctor iría para
estos jóvenes que desde muy temprana
edad comienzan a tener dudas sobre su su
identidad de género y comienzan a tener
momentos de dudas y necesitan
preguntarle a adultos sobre lo que les
está sucediendo este tipo de
conversaciones entonces son válidas en
el aula de clase
tendrían que preguntar sólo a sus padres
en principio diría yo porque son sus
padres los que van a poder determinar
acuérdate que stanley hablando
exclusivamente de esta ley es para niños
que están hasta tercer grado entonces si
ellos tienen alguna duda pueden hablar
con sus padres y los padres decidir ya
con un razonamiento un poco más adulto
obviamente es cómo canalizar esos esos
problemas o estatura que puedan tener
los niños y lo último que quería incluir
dentro de este punto es que la educación
es un tema completamente y estrictamente
estatal son los estados los que deciden
cómo educar a la gente a su población y
no es el gobierno federal si tienen
ciertos lineamientos en el estado y son
los estados quienes tienen la
jurisdicción general para poder decidir
cómo se debe realizar la educación
dentro de sus límites estatales
alejandro hay temor de que este tipo de
leyes como esta que ha sido impuesta en
el estado de florida sea un punto de
partida para un posible detrimento de la
educación sexual
en las escuelas en estado de florida que
esto sea un punto de partida para
empezar en poner más restricciones más
leyes que lleven precisamente a que este
tipo de temas comiencen a ser vetados o
restringidos en las aulas de clase y que
sea simplemente el inicio de digamos de
una bola de nieve que pueda
incrementarse
es muy muy muy interesante como el señor
de la flor se contradice a sí mismo
porque dice que está bien que los
estudiantes hable con sus compañeritos
que hablen con los maestros
espontáneamente pero que no hayan los
estándares oficiales para enseñar es
como decir no quieres hablar de drogas
con los estudiantes deja que hablen con
los compañeritos que ellos te van a
enseñar mejor es una es una una idea
completamente retrógrada es una idea que
viene de los 50 y lamentablemente no
está apta para el año 2020 como le dije
anteriormente los estudiantes no
solamente están aislados en su casa y en
el salón de clase los estudiantes ven a
las redes sociales televisión netflix
ellos están expuestos a todo y están muy
curiosos inclusive otro dato interesante
yo enseñé es para superior y cuando me
movía escuela intermedia con niños de 10
años pensé no voy a tener que estar
lidiando con cosas sexuales porque
person niño todo lo contrario encontrar
más preguntas más curiosidades le serví
de ejemplo todavía tengo estudiantes que
me dan las gracias por haber sido un
maestro abiertamente gay
tengo maestros amigos que son miembros
de la comunidad lgbt que se sienten con
miedo de ccoo simplemente hablar con los
estudiantes sobre temáticas que son
importantes lo que estamos es
retrocediendo en el tiempo y
lamentablemente el republicano no va a
poder detener el avance que han hecho
las personas lgtb de cv para asegurar
nuestros derechos humanos y nuestros
derechos igualitarios víctor usted
quiere responder algo a esto que comenta
alejandro adelante
sí yo creo que esto no es un tema de
retroceder es simplemente darle un
además a los padres en la potestad
que ya tienen de educar de poder educar
a sus hijos de la mejor manera y este
sin disminuir ningún derecho de ningún
estudiante dentro de florida no puedo
hablar de los de estado pero en función
de esta ley no sé de ésta no hay ninguna
violación a ningún derecho civil ni de
los alumnos ni de los profesores
entonces no creo que es un paso atrás en
funciona a
ningún aspecto
dentro de ésta florida
víctor que puede decir usted de esas
declaraciones que dio el presidente de
eeuu joe biden es sobre esta ley
impuesta en florida que la tildó de ley
odiosa que puede decir usted de este
señalamiento desde la casa blanca
bueno eso es este señalamiento va acorde
con todas las críticas que se ha
recibido desde la contienda del
demócrata no desde el partido demócrata
como le digo e incluso le están
indicando les han puesto está este apodo
de ley de no digas gay
para simplemente generar desconcierto y
decir cosas que no son esta ley es para
proteger el derecho de los padres en la
educación de las niñas
alejandro desde la defensa de los
derechos de la comunidad lgtb y de los
derechos de los menores también y de los
mismos derechos que tienen los
estadounidenses de estar a favor o en
contra de las decisiones que se puedan
tomar por parte de los gobiernos hay en
mente hay organizándose algún tipo de
movimiento o algo que vaya a
llevar alguna ley en contra o vaya a
promover un movimiento en contra para
revertir esta decisión del gobernador de
sántiz y de y del
congreso allí del gobierno estatal en
florida sobre esta legislación
la relación acaba de ser robada por el
gobernador a menos que cambiemos de
gobernador escuela eso no ha cambiado
pero lo que va a pasar actualmente
estamos busca estamos recopilando
personas y padres que están en contra
que les afecta personalmente esta ley
como por ejemplo cuando nosotros
peleamos por la igual la igualdad de
matrimonio nosotros conseguimos personas
al cual esto le afectaba personalmente y
llevamos eso a las cortes lo que va a
pasar con esta ley es que va a ser
ejecutada legalmente en las cortes hasta
que esto llegue a la corte suprema y se
determine que lo que son los desastres
ha hecho está en contra de los derechos
humanos y es un movimiento recto lograda
y simplemente político para comprar para
sus aspiraciones políticas para 2024
lamentablemente la comunidad de gmt
siempre ha sido un instrumento para los
republicanos
para animar a su base y como les dije
anteriormente las personas
no están dentro del closet no vamos a
desaparecer y simplemente vamos a luchar
para mantener nuestros derechos
-alejandro yo mencionaba al principio en
la introducción que el gobernador de
santis es un gobernador y es un político
que está en ascenso está allanando el
terreno para una posible candidatura en
el 2024 usted cree que este tipo de
medidas tiene algo de estrategia
política más allá de estar pensando en
el beneficio de los jóvenes y de los
menores de edad de la protección a la
hora de hablar sobre este tipo de temas
y también por darle una mayor potestad a
los padres por encima de los padres a la
hora de hablar sobre estos temas esto
tiene algo estrategia política sin duda
alguna el gobernador de sancti
simplemente quiere ser el presidente de
santis y quiere ser un clon del
expresidente trump es simplemente está
tratando de apelar a su base religiosa
de personas conservadoras extremistas
racistas homofóbicas y ese es el tipo de
votante que han de santis quieren
florida víctor le hago esa pregunta que
pienso estos señalamientos sobre estas
decisiones del gobernador de santis que
tiene mucho de estrategia política de
cara a su posible nominación como un
candidato republicano para la
presidencia
no lo sé no sé si es que está pensando
en en la posible elección el 2024
obteniendo está como digamos firmando
esta ley pero lo que no estoy de acuerdo
es que se señale que esto es para apelar
a un votante racista un votante
homofóbico etcétera porque él no tiene
ningún sentido
no tiene sentido jalar ciertas d
digamos ciertas quizá aspiraciones que
puedan tener los demás y atacar esa ley
en función a eso porque lo que se está
haciendo acá es simplemente defender la
educación en florida darle mayor derecho
a los padres en cuanto a los hijos y
además si quieren eventualmente tener
una educación sexual se le puede dar a
la educación sexual a los niños que son
mayores de digamos que ya puedan tener
una capacidad suficiente para para poder
tener este tipo de
información o sea unos niños que ya
están digamos en la escuela secundaria
osasuna el problema pero los niños de 67
años que no saben nada de esto que se
les que se les esté que se les adoctrina
en ese sentido pues hay que proteger
nuestro es un tema de protección para
los niños y de empoderamiento para los
padres aquí no tiene que ver nada así no
sé nada de retroceso eso me parece algo
que no hubiera caso
víctor a usted dice que esto es para
beneficio de los menores de los
estudiantes que están en el jardín de
infantes hasta 3º de primaria de
educación básica cuáles van a ser los
beneficios esto en que los va a ayudar a
ellos no hablar de este tipo de temas es
recibir
simplemente información básica para
entender algún tipo de escenarios que se
les pueden presentar en el futuro
porque quizá en ese momento no nos van a
entender o sea cómo es que tú le das a
la información que quizá le puede dar
mayor
mayores dudas o actuar de una forma en
que ellos de repente no quieren actuar
porque no solamente es dar información
hemos visto y los comenté en un
principio que esta ley no nace
simplemente por querer atacar como
ciertas tenemos cierto sector dice a
determinados a determinadas
organizaciones a determinado sector de
la población sino simplemente nace como
respuesta a lo que ha existido y lo que
se verifica anteriormente en que es leal
y obligado a estos niños a la marcha que
hay dentro de la escuela o este vestido
de mujer o de hombres perdón de mujer a
niños cosa que ha sido una reacción yo
creo que es razonable para poder
proteger a los menores que son un además
muy pequeños si está más o menos 5 6 7 8
años alejandro ya le voy a dar la
palabra quiero hacerle la última
pregunta víctor si no se está
subestimando a los menores de edad
precisamente porque son pequeños pero si
ellos ya están preguntando por estos
temas no se está subestimando pensando
que ellos simplemente no les interesa y
que no entienden de qué se les está
hablando pero ellos en algunos casos
está atravesando por una situación
porque hay una confusión en su género y
ellos mismos se están formulando
preguntas
correcto pero estas preguntas la pueden
discutir con sus padres que quienes son
los que tienen la obligación el deber el
derecho de educar a sus hijos si son los
padres los que en ese momento de edad
otro momento de la vida de esta persona
puede de estos niños pueden tomar la
decisión de cómo afrontar esta situación
si lo van a hacer directamente con los
niños o de repente quizá
tratar de buscar otro tipo de ayuda
profesional pero aquí el punto es quién
tiene
y quién tiene digamos quién está mejor
posicionado para poder educar a su hijo
en ese momento sobre ese punto yo creo
que los padres en vez de los maestros
con una currícula que puede ser impuesta
o mal impuesto los padres que no tienen
ningún tipo de capacitación referente a
estos temas y muchos de ellos también
desconocen este tipo de temáticas
alejandro su opinión sobre sobre este
tema sobre esto que estamos hablando de
subestimar a los menores que ya están
haciendo este tipo de preguntas y los
padres no se le está poniendo mucha
presión a los padres a la hora de tener
que asumir este tipo de direccionamiento
empezar a entender este tipo de temas
bajo qué parámetros se les está poniendo
en escrutinio con esta situación
como le dije anteriormente tal vez haya
algunos algunos padres que existen
equipados con las herramientas
necesarias para enseñarle a sus hijos
pero la mayoría de los padres no están
equipados para para enseñar la opción
muy interesante que el señor de la flor
vuelve en tepito tease diga que los
niños están equipados para para o no lo
entienden los niños yo dije
anteriormente le digo ahora la edad
promedio para que un niño encuentre un
niño o una niña encuentra imágenes
pornográficas en la tele 7 años 7 no los
niños no se empiezan a violar o nos
pesan a sentir abuso desde los 8 años
adelante porque no entienden lo que le
pasó anteriormente todo lo contrario hay
niños que son infantes en niños que son
muy pequeñitos que no comprenden porque
no han tenido esa intervención de los
padres de cómo proteger su propio cuerpo
como en cómo entender la distancia
social y lamentablemente los padres si
estarán en pagos algunos por como dije
anteriormente la educación sexual es
dinámica cambia constantemente y los
padres no están equipados y entrenados
por un profesional para enseñar a los
niños sobre sexualidad y muchos de ellos
aún no comprenden
uso de pronombres como le dije
anteriormente el sexo biológico se
determina por diferentes o por al menos
88 vías física no y entre me también que
hay un por ciento de la población
estadounidense y en general del mundo
que son intersex o que no están
definidos 100%
biológicamente ser que hacemos personas
no podemos no podemos decir con la mano
no podemos permitir que los gigantes se
sigan en la ignorancia simple piensa
alejandro para el cierre víctor también
para finalizar ya el programa ustedes
que creen que va a suceder con este tipo
de ley esto será el punto de partida
para que otros estados en la unión
americana también adopten este tipo de
de leyes o que esto tal vez se extienda
a otros países también de américa latina
alejandro muy puntual por favor
lamentablemente esto es el comienzo de
una cadena de legislación que se va para
comenzar con el sur con los estados
republicanos y va a continuar
a menos que se detenga en la corte
suprema por eso que importante llevar
esta espera que está esta lucha a las
cortes y víctor su opinión sobre este
tema esto será un punto de partida puede
servir de ejemplo para otros estados que
quieran también darle protección a los
menores de edad y otorguen esta potestad
a los padres para que hablen sobre la
identidad de género a temprana edad con
sus hijos y no sea discutido en las
escuelas
bueno hay muchos estados que están
regulando esto cada uno es totalmente
independiente y cada uno puede poder
tomar la decisión que más del idioma le
favorezca a sus a su población y yo creo
que eventualmente podrán existir ciertas
demandas a nivel judicial pero yo creo
que una vez más no se se está violando
ningún derecho civil por lo tanto estimo
que podrían ser desestimadas sin
judicialmente también pues a victoria
alejandro les agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros en el programa y haber
puesto sobre la mesa del debate sus
diferentes puntos de vista en torno a
este tema esta ley que ha generado mucha
polémica no solamente en el estado de
florida sino también en eeuu y por
supuesto ha trascendido fronteras en
varias partes del mundo se está
discutiendo una leyes similares
parecidas a ésta que ha sido puesta en
marcha en el estado de florida en el sur
de eeuu ustedes pueden seguir dejando
sus preguntas y sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales sigan con france24
[Música]